Well, it's official.
Ursula Vanderlein has announced her reelection bid
as European Commission President.
The 65 year old is the first woman to hold the role
and has LED the block through some challenging times,
including the COVID 19 pandemic,
the cost of living crisis
and the Russian invasion of Ukraine.
The reelection announcement
was made at a meeting of Germany's Christian
Democratic Union party in Berlin on Monday.
She will be confirmed by her European
People's Party grouping
and instantly becomes the front runner for the job,
but the possibility of extending her term
depends on the outcome of June's European elections.
The commission
president is appointed by the 27 EU leaders
and there's an unwritten
rule that it goes to a candidate from the largest party.
The chosen person then needs to have their appointment
confirmed by the European Parliament.
Vanderlein has had a rocky few months
with a push back against the EU Green deal
and criticism for her handling of the Israel
Palestine conflict.
But her strong relationships with EU leaders
and the EPP's polling numbers
put her in a strong position to stay on as European
Commission president for a second term.